-It is great to see you.
Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," bud.
-Thank you, man.
I'm so excited to see people.
-Yeah, it's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're so excited to see you.
You look great, buddy.
-Oh, you know what?
The pandemic, man.
Let me tell you,
I lost 70 pounds.
-Holy -- good for you.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People ask me all the time,
"What's your secret?"
I said, "It's no secret.
They closed
all the restaurants."
[ Laughter ]
-They just closed it down.
-And I'm still wearing the same
shirt that I was wearing
when I was still
70 pounds heavier
because I plan to eat again.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
The last time
you were on our show,
you looked sharp, buddy.
But here's you backstage.
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah, look at that.
-It's rare to see you in a suit.
-The one and only time
I ever wore a suit
was on your show,
because the time before that,
I was wearing shorts,
and I heard you
make a comment about,
"Thanks for dressing up."
And I'm like, "Uuuugh."
And my family saw the show,
and they were like...
[ Speaking,
swearing in Spanish ]
And I'm like, "All right, look,
I get it, I get it."
-Yeah, exactly right.
-You know what she's saying.
-[ Laughing ]
-Something around that, yeah.
-So I says, "When I come back --
if I get invited back --"
I go, "I'm gonna go all out,
and I'm gonna wear a suit."
And put the picture up again?
I had a little bit of an issue.
This is your wardrobe area,
and these two --
You know, I think
they still work here.
-Yes.
-Apparently, what happened is,
I had a wardrobe
malfunction, okay?
Yeah, because I never
wore pants.
Clearly, I did it today.
But the pant leg ripped.
And so, you know, I was
bringing sexy back that day.
And --
-Before the show?
-As you were getting ready
to introduce me.
And so, we had
to stop everything,
and I had to go in the back,
and they had to sew it up
and fix me up
and tape me together.
I mean, look at me right --
I don't wear --
Some people wear suits,
and they look nice, okay?
And some look like
affordable lawyers.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, no.
You look -- Come on.
-Eh?
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-A low budget secret service guy
right there.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know how he got shot.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
I almost want to say,
"Look at you now,"
because you're going to be
performing at Dodger Stadium --
the first comedian ever
to perform at Dodger Stadium.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's already sold out.
You're adding, like, another
second show or something.
This is an audience
of 40,000 people.
-I know, I'm like
the Bad Bunny of comedy.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you excited about this?
-He's a "Fluffy Bunny."
It's -- It's --
[ Laughter ]
If we ever do a collab,
it's gonna be perfect.
Fluffy Bad Bunny, yeah.
-Fluffy Bad Bunny, yeah.
-It's surreal,
because it's like, you know,
whenever I tell people
I'm doing Dodger Stadium,
they're like, "Well, what --
are you singing
the national anthem?
Are you cleaning it?
What are you doing?"
And I'm like,
"No, I'm performing."
They're like, "Do they have,
like, a small room?"
It's like the Super Bowl
for a comedian, you know?
-Yeah, of course it is.
-And not everybody gets
to play the Super Bowl,
so I feel very fortunate
that it's happening,
and it's happening
in my hometown.
And, yeah, it's already --
-Well done, buddy.
You put the work in,
and, man, you're funny.
It's gonna be great.
Congratulations on that.
That's a dream come true.
That's beyond a dream.
How could you even
dream about that?
-Yeah, you know, you say,
"How can you dream
of something like that?"
Because people ask me
all the time,
"Did you ever think that
it could get this big?"
And I'm like, "No,
my only goal in life
when I first started
doing standup was,
I just wanted to pay my rent."
-Yeah.
-Because people always say,
"Reach for the stars."
It's unrealistic.
You what I'm saying?
I tell people,
"Reach for the second floor."
[ Laughter ]
-You might be able --
-Yeah, and this way,
if you end up on the roof,
you are an overachiever.
-That's exactly correct, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're going to debut something
exclusively just for us tonight.
What's your story behind these?
-So, a couple years ago,
I started this
beautiful relationship
with a company called Funko.
And Funko has these Pop figures,
and basically,
they're the hottest thing
out there.
Every year at Comic-Con,
I-i mean, you know,
millions of these figures
have been sold.
And when I approached them
to see if there was interest
in having a comedian Pop,
they were like,
"Well, we don't have a category
for comedians."
And I'm like,
"Well, maybe we can start one."
And next thing I know,
we made a little deal,
and they came out
with a figure for me.
-It's sold out.
-Yes, I've sold a lot of those.
-Yeah, a lot.
-A lot, a lot. [ Laughs ]
-A lot.
-Thank you, Funko.
But to commemorate
the Dodger Stadium show,
Funko made me a special one
specifically for Dodger Stadium,
and it comes out this week.
And this is the first time
anyone's gonna see it.
-Here we go. Quest, can I get
a little drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
Ladies and gentlemen...
Stadium Fluffy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at this.
Stadium Fluffy.
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
Congratulations, buddy.
Couldn't happen
to a better guy, man.
-Thank you.
-Gabriel Iglesias, everybody.
Go see him perform
at Dodger Stadium
May 6th and 7th.